[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight just in case you were wondering
whether the president was serious about
the border crisis last night he
delivered a decisive answer in a
surprise move the White House announced
that unless Mexico halts the flow of
illegal immigrants into the United
States the US will starting on June 10th
imposed a 5% tariff on all imports from
that country if the situation doesn't
improve going forward that tariff will
rise by five percent a month every month
by October there will be a 25% tariff on
all goods coming from Mexico from
avocados to automobiles so let's be
honest about what that would mean the US
imports 372 billion dollars worth of
goods from Mexico every year the prices
on all of those goods would likely go up
consumers would feel that so would
businesses critics claim that the
tariffs would slow the US economy and
they're likely right over time they
probably would but we ought to impose
them anyway not every government policy
is a pure economic calculation when the
United States is attacked by a hostile
foreign power it must strike back and
make no mistake Mexico is a hostile
foreign power for decades the Mexican
government has sent its poor north to
our country this has allowed that
country's criminal oligarchy to maintain
power and get even richer but at great
expense to us the flood of illegal
workers into the United States has
damaged our communities ruined our
schools burdened our health care system
and fractured our national unity it has
suppressed wages for our most vulnerable
it has been a slow-motion attack on this
country and its effects have been
devastating there's not what a real
debate about that the numbers are clear
honest people admit it but our leaders
are not honest in the hours after the
president's announcement they
instinctively sided with Mexico
well tariffs man is back the president
is threatening a new country with new
tariffs this time Mexico
it sounds muy fuerte very strong but
whom will it squeeze US or Mexico no
mistake about it US consumers will bear
the brunt
these tariffs whether it's a negotiating
tactic or an attempt to distract it's
still surprised everyone nothing short
of a political stunt so you know I don't
know if it was changing the subject from
Muller I can't figure it out
John Kasich can't figure it out it's too
complicated for him but the light of the
week the award for the most disingenuous
response from a sitting world leader has
to go to the left-wing Mexican President
Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador in response
to the tariff threat and lo issued a
statement that warned quote social
problems are not resolved with taxes or
coercive measures end quote
in other words says the liberal
government isn't the solution hilarious
Weber's abidor went on to lecture the US
president about America's national
values because of course the president
Mexico is just that arrogant and
presumptuous to do that can you imagine
quote the Statue of Liberty is not an
empty symbol
well Mexico's corrupt ruling class
believes it is America's duty to absorb
their country's problems forever the
American Left agrees there is
contemptuous of America as the Mexican
government is